know who's the hottest guy
that's a good question probably thor
right dude chris [ __ ]
don't do that right guys
hey you guys agree right now
it's between jason mama and thor did you
ever watch his workouts no people
for sure usada's not knocking on chris
hemsworth's door but you don't get that
big without immense amounts of hard work
yeah there's no way you just don't
people think he always just took good
steroids bro
relax can you get those girls off the
screen and can we get back to that hot
guy mark thanks a lot dude my bad dude
come on yeah tv
you got to use the ad blocker bro
sound al is trying so hard to
participate it's so funny
isn't he good looking
good he's kind of hot who's who's your
number one guy out who is it
[Laughter]
you know how long we've been in this
podcast i know al's number one guy okay
go it's the the guy from this is us yeah
yeah
a drama no yeah it's um
obviously in the white guys oh it's the
white guy from this is uh yeah yeah
oh wow justin hartley justin hartley
he's no
that's like the ultimate insult you know
bro what you're no thor yeah i mean
who is your number one guy
hold
that's your number one guy of any dude
in the [ __ ] planet that's the guy who
no that's jake this is the guy
cheers morgan
bro not thor guy but now now it's okay
right he's like oh yeah he's number one
face
picking all the same guy like
who's your number one not guy uh idris
elba really that's something that's
everything
watch luther tell me you don't fall in
love with yourself right he likes
personality
he just has a confidence about it
yeah joe's just about body dude
you're assuming you would be the top
he's assuming he would be the guy
that's what that was that's a great
point that's 100 percent what it is he's
like just my man
and you're like too old
no i don't think that but i don't think
about
see this thing
look at me dorothy [ __ ] around bro
you haven't said anything catholicism
have anything to do with it
the most beautiful man is jesus christ
real talk lord savior dude no jesus god
fire story or or malibu from american
gladiator bro
oh yeah mark got ombre in his hair one
time because of malibu one time
does he keep doing it
oh yeah bro malibu was my number one
yeah who kind of got it bro come on